- The paper airplane you
folded in middle school,
horrible design.
But, I've thrown a
paper airplane 214 feet.
I'm John Collins.
I am the paper airplane guy.
World record holder for
paper aircraft distance.
(playful music)
The year we got the record was 2012.
It was, you know, one of the great
days in my life, actually.
You know, I look back at my child being born
and the world record.
Those are great moments for me.
I named the world record
plane after my wife.
The name of the design is Susanne.
This is how you fold Susanne.
You start with the short
side of the paper out.
(quickly talking)
It's just eight simple folds.
There are a lot of different
kinds of folding techniques
and a lot of different
kinds of paper airplanes.
There's planes that boomerang back.
There are planes that are
made to fly straight very far.
There are planes that are made to stay
in the air for a long time.
Every great paper airplane,
distance or time aloft,
has very accurate folding.
Most people want to know how
I got into paper airplanes,
and the reality is I
never got out of them.
I am curious by nature.
I love math and science.
The cool thing about paper
airplanes is it's a way
to actually discover
something real about flight.
What most people don't
know is that we don't
know the exact cause and effect for lift.
Every little paper airplane throw
is like a little science experiment.
Here's the laboratory,
right here in your hand
that you could use to do real science.
Teachers kind of don't like
kids to do paper airplanes.
It has this bad boy kinda
renegade reputation.
If they could discover
that paper airplanes
actually are science.
That they're doing science
and having fun doing it.
I think that's an
incredible breakthrough.
Paper airplane throwing
class, yes (chuckles).
(playful music)